kinsley I'm been later won't figure that  one out  I am extremely appreciative that  Amanda's let me meet the kids today it's  a big step in our relationship it's  needed though and I think if we're gonna  see if there is a future we need to you  know see how it be as a family nice to  meet you finally  I've heard a lot of great things I heard  you like coming to the beach okay here  I'm gonna help you out with this keeping  this together let's pile up some sand so  it gets nice and yeah let's sick octopus  right there  yeah push down should we step on it too  you think let's let's step on it step  right up on it perfect all right  now this even comes out  perfect look at that there's an octopus  yeah all right ready  oh he's ready go get him you're not  gonna catch me Oh Tagg gonna chase me  you